look at these muscles he's not miss leg
day hey bro come back here what a fight
yeah you want to be you want to be my
hello my name's Ann Jones and today
we're going to be looking at viral
videos of kangaroos
[Music]
hope there are no kangaroo mating videos
because that's just horrendous it looks
like it's a paraglider you can just see
a shadow and holy moly whoa whoa okay
that's really odd behavior you don't see
this normally kangaroos aren't
aggressive towards humans where you know
the ones who are potentially going to be
hunting them so they normally run the
opposite direction
maybe the kangaroo was just insanely
scared and confused and just took a
flying jump at this guy all right we've
got soup and gurus and we're in
someone's front yard Skippy would be
absolutely cenario I think that these
will both be males it's normal that
males will be fighting and generally not
females they're trying to sort out a bit
of a hierarchy he'll stand as tall as a
person especially when they're upright
and being aggressive like this it's a
head tilt yeah yeah the grapple without
looking that's because they're actually
trying to get their head away from being
scratched or you know your brain is
really important to your functioning so
you want to do everything you can to
protect it in a fight and they will sit
back onto that big tail and actually do
a kangaroo kick like I'm this and that
can disembowel an opponent if the angle
is right so they also have really strong
thick skin on their tummies to protect
against other kangaroos I wouldn't get
that close
it's like Mortal Kombat Ozai it's really
unusual to see extended kangaroo fights
they normally sort it out pretty quickly
so these two guys look pretty evenly
matched imagine how much energy this
sort of thing would take they're going
to be tired injured hungry after they do
this and then they've got to go out and
bonk a lady so it's hard oh dear that's
not good so we've got tourists
scratching a kangaroo who is standing
upright with its head back oh and we've
got a grapple or there's going to be a
kick this guy doesn't know what's going
no scratch he's grappling he's not
cuddling this is a dominance thing yep
don't have your child near that kangaroo
yep and see more aggressive see getting
bigger and bigger getting more tense
even when they're in wildlife parks they
might be habituated to humans they're
not domestic animals so us thinking that
they like a good scratch around the chin
like maybe a cat in that case completely
wrong he's lucky he didn't get a smash
in the stomach from that kangaroo is he
up at the window oh I think he's he's
seeing himself and thinking that it's
possibly another kangaroo must been
really confusing for him windows
beautiful human invention really bad for
wildlife they don't see glass like we
see glass oh he's gonna hurt himself you
can see here really clearly that he's
got huge claws on those little arms
there a weapon sure they can injure you
they can scratch you they can do all
sorts of things so you shouldn't
approach them but people who do die and
it involves kangaroos is generally road
accidents all of these videos are so
interesting because each in their own
way show interactions between humans and
kangaroos sometimes we want them to be
close and be cute and we want to give
them food but we don't want to play by
their rules of social hierarchy and
that's really can
using for kangaroos so the best thing
that you can possibly do is admire all
of their traits and think that they're
wonderful and provides space for them in
your world but perhaps don't get too
close to our wild kangaroos so that's it
for this video but there are more to
watch in the how deadly series so you
should be able to click on some links
and if you've got an idea for an animal
video why don't you send it in to us or
leave a comment below anyway until next
time catch you later